c'est une sorte de résidence d'artistes
pour cuisinier à esvres-sur-indre un
restaurant éphémère vient d'ouvrir ses
portes sur le domaine hôtelier de Loire
vallée Lodge jusqu'en septembre
l'aspératus c'est son nom va accueillir
non pas un mais cinq chefs le premier
est un anglais Romainville la rencontre
Daniel Morgane est un chef cuisinier
baroudeur il s'est illustré à Copenhague
à Tokyo en Inde il revient tout juste de
Colombie et se pose durant un petit mois
à l'aspératus le nouveau restaurant de
terrasse de Loire Vallet lodge à
esvres-sur-indre aussi à l'aise pour
charger le four à bois que pour
travailler en finesse les asperges le
chef anglais a une cuisine rock n' roll
tout en braise et en élégance sélection
de
légumes de printemps avec beaucoup de
l'aigu avec le feu du feu
fumer
roadstad fumé et en vinaigrette avec le
charbon aussi avec
[Musique]
pour conquérir et fidéliser sa clientèle
le complexe hôtelier d'evres mise sur la
diversité à l'image de ces Lodge dans
les arbres de l'art dans les bois et sur
les pelouses et maintenant dans son
deuxième restaurant un chef c'est
quelque part un artiste et donc c'est de
mettre en avant des talents et de la
même manière qu'on a plusieurs
plusieurs sculpteurs plusieurs peintres
on a plusieurs chefs et ça nous fait
plaisir de faire découvrir
aux personnes qui habitent dans la
région des talents qui peuvent être des
talons colombiens basque anglais
espagnol en complément de la gastronomie
plus classique
connue dans en Touraine qui est la terre
de gastronomie
ainsi cinq grands chefs cuisiniers vont
se succéder derrière le four à bois
jusqu'à la fin du mois de septembre